the blazes conservative millennial Ally
Stuckey joins in studio to discuss the
whiniest generation there will be
wailing and gnashing of teeth then dr.
Bickley and Emily Butler joined the
panel of deplorable z' to discuss
Republican propaganda my favorite Jimmy
Kimmel's latest humorless hacking for
Democrats and meat-eating vegetarians on
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
nul show
[Music]
my cup it runneth over my leftist tears
mug it runneth over
this week yesterday you saw we had Roman
come in we had we had what my first day
with roaming and today back to back
we're joined by Allie Stuckey all the
way from Texas in the studio so we have
to talk you I think you are the foremost
expert on whiny snowflakes this is true
my way officially you know I am in in a
previous life I've been an actor I've
been in numerous terrible indie movies
nobody's seen except at 3:00 in the
morning on cable you you are teaching me
things about the art of method acting
I'll show the latest clip of Ali's
duckie so I just graduated from college
last week and Harvard actually and I
started my new job on Monday so
obviously on Sunday night I wanted to go
out with my friends and celebrate um it
was a late night so Monday morning first
day I rolled in around 10:30 set up my
desk and my boss my white male boss had
the audacity to come up to me and say
where have you been where have I been
well I've been celebrating and I've been
partying and then I've been sleeping and
I've been resting because you know what
this is a stressful time and you know
what I feel a little bit pressured and a
little bit endangered right now I do not
feel safe so I'll just leave and come
back when you've changed your tune mr.
white male boss and you know what he
said to me he said you could pack up
your stuff and go and I said what did
you just say to me I can pack up my
stuff and go I'm fired just because I
was late on my first day to work because
I'm not doing anything
are you kidding me I mean talk about
sexism this is the white male pager I
can't work right here talk about
discrimination so now it's Tuesday I'm
back I've got my protesting signs in the
trunk and I'm gonna show them who's boss
and I am going to show them that this
millennial generation is not taking that
crap from baby virgin Xers okay we're
gonna do whatever we want to and if we
can't do that and if we don't feel safe
then we're just gonna quit and that is a
real threat give this woman an Oscar
somebody get that was the most
incredible performance not just of a
millennial but the most incredible
performance I've seen in years yeah you
know I appreciate
it was absolutely the words I feel
endangered
I feel unsafe but it really I'm not
being facetious in any way you nail so
many points for getting to well thank
you yeah the craziness now by the way
just maybe people who are listening or
watching don't believe me here is a clip
from my own dear beleaguered alma mater
Yale from just two years ago here's a
clip of an actual alright goodbye
everybody
I can't show after watching that but by
the way just for the record that Yale
student was girl named Jarrell and
Luther and she who asked who the eff
hired you she was on the committee that
gave him his position she was a student
on the committee that hired him just a
little bit of fun I would have loved if
he had just answered her and said well
actually it was you watching that I
actually do think maybe you need to up
the hysteria in your own satirical but I
have to ask you channeling the movie as
good as it gets
yeah how do you play Millennials so well
okay this is my tried and true method
you can adopt it if you want to for the
next time you audition for an indie film
so I I turn on the news I hear something
I see a clip like this and I'm like wow
this is this is really happening
for some reason I always get in my car
I don't know why I get in my car and I
say okay let me like channel these
people let me make sure that my brain
turns to mush because it's a safe yes
and tried to dial back my and what's
that called EQ emotional intelligence
back to like age 12 11 or something like
that and then I just kind of go from
there really I just turned on my camera
and I start talking I don't like write
it out or anything that's how easy it is
because it mirrors reality so closely
that's probably why the majority of
people that watch them think that I'm
serious do they they actually they can't
tell the satire from the reality no no
they can't they just blow right past the
fact that it's called the conservative
millennial and they just start typing
away but that's just internet trolls for
you this raises a real question that I
have for the culture at this moment
especially this generation are they
beyond satire have they transcended
parody to the point that the they have
so embraced the absurd that it can't be
funny anymore yeah you call the absurd
to an absurd person it nothing rings
funny there's no standard anymore right
it's just sad we were talking about this
earlier if you live in irony is anything
really ironic anymore or is it just
reality when do we lose sight of what's
R&E and what's not I love irony that's
probably more what this is and satire I
just like playing upon the
ridiculousness of the irony in which
they live unknowingly but unfortunately
so many people live in that space that
it is very hard to distinguish between
what's true and what's not but that's
okay I think that's all the more reason
to do it so people hear the absurdity
and the logic at the core of their
argument so they can say well is that
really what I sound like
and but do they hear it is there these
millennia I mean we could do we could do
the show every day about how insane this
generation of people is yeah basically
we do that anyway but do they do we give
them in any way a bad rap like what is
causing it on the one hand it's
hilarious it's great to laugh at this
chick at Yale who's screeching in her
betters face but on the other hand it's
really sad it's sad to see ignorant
students
saying we don't want to learn anything
we think that we know the whole world
and we're going to inveigh against you
and get you fired
yeah well unfortunately it's kind of a
long history lesson I think I think it
goes back to our parents and the
generation before that and then the
generation before that I think the
further my personal theory is the
further we get away from the Great
Depression and the Great War is the
further we are or the closer we are to
entitlement the further we are away from
hard work and really understanding what
it means to work hard for the for a
dollar and what the value of the dollar
is and not having the privilege of
having helicopter parents and parents
that convince you that you are special
no matter what honorable mentions trophy
participation trophy all those things
are relatively new and we didn't choose
them unfortunately our parents did and
so I can't say of course it's such like
a millennial to kind of shift
responsibility but it's not all of our
fault ability it's mom and dad's fault
but really I mean that's part of it and
so and then of course the last eight
years of Barack Obama's presidency
certainly didn't help that if we were
predisposed to being entitled certainly
everything that Obama stood for I think
conditioned that even further and that
was evidenced by the fact that Bernie
Sanders received more votes from
Millennials than Trump and Clinton did
combined so it just kind of feeds into
our predisposition for wanting free
stuff and thinking that we deserve not
just material things but also to be
intellectually coddled that the world
that the world is fair that the world
owes you something but how is it this
brings up two questions not all of us
are insane not all of us have lost our
minds babe we're gonna we're gonna go on
and save America but really I mean there
is this young right-wing movement that
does cut through this craziness so is it
that soft times can't make great men you
know that you really you're a product of
your times is there any way to cut
through that and and then we'll have to
talk about Texas in California but is
there how do we rise above it when we
grew up in basically a
luxurious time yeah um I think probably
the first thing that I always advise
Millennials and especially college
students to do which by the way I found
out for the first time when I was
speaking out of college - the other day
I was talking about Millennials and you
know entitlement everything we're
talking about and this little old guy
raised his hand and he was like oh by
the way we're actually not Millennials
we're Generation Z and I realized for
the first time that I'm old but anyway
how to break through that I mean I
always tell the first the first thing I
tell people is to read just read I mean
our parents read so much more than we
ever did all we do is scroll through our
ideological echo chambers made possible
by a Facebook algorithm but you know
what I always say I'm sorry to
contradict you Ali I always say to watch
a lot of podcasts watch the podcasts
send them to your friends particularly
young people you bring a lot of young
people on anyway that's just my two
cents but you think we should read books
I do I do think we get we can read books
but there are other ways so if you're
not a reader if you don't like to read
you can also listen a podcast for
example I listen to this podcast I also
listen to liberal podcasts I listen to
pods of America I love I love the
liberal podcasts pod save America they
they are maybe it's it's not proper
etiquette to talk badly about people on
the left doing podcasts it's terrible I
mean they're so tired I listen to pods
of America I'm like okay got it got the
snowflake down my fianceé sweet little
Lisa turns me on to this she said like I
listened to all of your shows so I
wanted to listen to some left-wing there
are no arguments
it's just exasperation yes swear words
and exasperation there's and there's
more ways my favorites yeah so I think
it takes more effort probably than it
used to to break out of our ideological
echo chamber simply because everything
that has been made convenient to us in
the form of you know social media and
information that we get from social
media it's tailored to what we already
think and so because of that especially
if you are on the left and all you're
going to get is someone that bolsters
your bias and if that's the case then
feelings of entitlement
and everything that we've just been
talking about is only going to increase
so what I encourage people to do people
like you and me who are just terribly
logical it's because we do break out of
those echo chambers and we allow
ourselves to be intellectually chat yeah
intellectually challenged that kind of
sounds like that's a bad thing but
intellectually I guess what am I trying
to say just help me to edify edified I
know I just like you I'm very often
overwhelmed by the strength of my own
logic it's really it's the weight of
glory is what it is right I feel a great
weight of glory no I agree with you
obviously it you need a curiosity and
people who think the world owes them
something often aren't that curious now
this brings me to my as my sales pitch
to you is that you you're in Texas yes
there are a lot of great outlets like
the blaze into Steve graders in Texas a
lot of people are there I've never lived
in a conservative place in my whole life
I've only lived in New York I lived in
New Haven and very liberal campus Los
Angeles is it better for conservatives
to live in red states or blue states or
should we be surrounded by people with
whom we agree or people who are
absolutely out of their minds that's a
really good question well I just fear
for you people better over here yeah yes
that y'all are gonna end up betraying us
because see in Texas I'm around so many
other conservatives that when the rest
of the world is going crazy we're like
okay this secession thing like are we
gonna do it and we can kind of bond over
that kind of stuff um y'all are kind of
you know y'all are isolated so I just
fear for you guys that y'all are gonna
end up going off the deep end peer
pressured into liberalism the other fear
for our lives is that you know every
time Steve Reder gets jihad in Texas
right he can go reach for one of the
7,000 guns within arm's length yes here
it's much more difficult I don't know
even how y'all deal with that that's
that's my biggest worry that it is true
yeah it's really hard I think in
California now it's illegal to possess
even one round of ammo you can only have
0 round magazines and your guidance
perfect yes we're gonna figure out a
workaround for it hopefully I think
that's my next satire video
excellent there there we go I'll take a
story credit because I've always I've
liked being in left-wing places because
it has totally you have to defend your
views that's that's a really good point
you become an apologist for conservatism
you have yeah I mean I think Yale I
totally see your fear I think most
normal people go to Yale and then 97% of
them become left-wing automatons but
there's this great 3% that come out like
more reactionary than Genghis Khan you
know you come out just yeah absolutely I
mean probably too far you know yeah but
that you just react against it yeah and
I think that's really important I think
that you set a great example for the
rest of us Millennials whether you're
whether you're on the right or the left
do you make absolutely a good point that
we all should become apologists for our
beliefs and I don't necessarily have to
do that quite as much when I work at the
blaze and live in Texas I went to school
in South Carolina and then I lived in
Georgia so I'm just like bouncing around
to the red states this is interesting
too though and I we have a game we have
to get to this is I've been planning
this out all morning this is I think
it's the hardest game it's harder than
chess or go that that Chinese game but
we'll get to that in one second because
I feel I see your point a lot of times
people who grow up with an idea they
rebel against it they get bored with it
they don't it's easy to fall away the
easiest way to find an ex-catholic is to
see who went to Catholic school and then
they always end up becoming atheists
afterward because they don't like the
nuns you've always been a conservative
yes Christian I have yes I have I grew
up a conservative Christian we grew up
watching Fox News my dad's actually a
politician in Texas so I know it sounds
like I didn't have much of a choice they
brainwashed me from an early but you
didn't labelled no well I know I didn't
rebel actually I would say in college my
ideas strengthened even further even
from a faith standpoint and from a
political standpoint I didn't actually
get into politics until a couple years
after college when I looked around and
realized that all of my very
well-informed and well-educated friends
just had no idea what was going on in
the world and how it really
to them which is why I berth to the
conservative millennial and started
making videos mostly for my friends and
then it took off immediately and you
were picked up by the place like not
really not immediately it took it took a
little bit but yeah I didn't take very
long and now I'm on the Michael Noel's
shows I'm just the peak it's all
downhill from here Ali as well do you
think because I asked this question a
lot I always get this in the mailbag
how much does the Jesus matter to the
conservatism I think it was a friend of
mine Elena plot once described
conservatism as Jesus guns and
capitalism how important is a
Christianity or a belief in God to this
huge generation of nuns people who grew
up without religion how important is the
religion to conservative policy yeah
well I think that conservatism is it is
necessarily a little bit subjective and
so it kind of depends on what exactly
you feel is most important to conserve I
certainly don't think it's absolutely
necessary to be Christian or even to
believe in God to believe that the
Constitution is inherently good and that
it's a good foundation upon which we
should be building our country I don't
think necessarily you have to believe in
a higher power to do that I think it
absolutely helps I think it helps to say
this is where my moral compass comes
from because Jesus told me that I am
supposed to love others the way that I
love myself I can always go back to that
and so yes it kind of I guess makes it
easier in a way or they go hand in hand
very well because say you don't have a
faith at all it very easily to me goes
into the direction of saying well why
would you have to care about anyone
except for you know survival of the
fittest so for me they go hand in hand
very well however I have a very good
friend who is an atheist who doesn't
believe in any way that you need a
religion to be a great person or to be a
conservative and it works for him so I
certainly can't tell him that he's not a
true conservative at least in the
secular sense simply because he doesn't
believe me you might yeah he might be a
conservative but he might
Andrew Klavan always says you can be a
conservative and an atheist you just
can't make sense and so it might well be
the case that a conservative thinks well
life liberty and property are pretty
good things too to call natural rights
and they might believe that and they
might want to promote that and that
that's all well and good by me right but
they might not understand why those are
natural right and what I would say to
that as well and what I have told my
atheist friend is that by holding on to
those things without the foundation or
without God being the foundation of
those things you still have a faith you
were just saying that you don't believe
in these in anything but you actually
have a faith in that and you have a
faith in what our Constitution says
you're just choosing to not put your
faith in God but you still have a face
that's a good point hopefully it won't
be ripped up like the bad seeds that
fall on the side of the road a warning
to you atheist conservatives well
parables how about that okay we're
getting too serious we're getting into
parables and mustard seeds so now we
have to get to this game basically this
is I call this game
I've passed you out little cards you'll
notice the cards say under 10 or over 20
the purpose of this game is to I'm gonna
have Marshall read out a quote and the
quote was either said by a millennial or
an adult or some whiny adult or a
toddler or a young child so it's gonna
be you have to guess based on just the
quote whether the person is under 10 or
over 20 for this we're going to have to
bring on our other two panelists we have
Emily Butler and we have dr. Bickley the
doctor himself the 8,000 d LOL
absolutely thank you for joining us get
ready this is a very important game the
points really really matter all right is
everybody ready for the questions
I am ready Marshall shoot when you're
clear there we go
the first quote in my heart I'm still
little I could have heard that a Yale
over 20 okay that is a nine year old
named did we all we all said over 20
whoa you are
got tripped up whoa you're treating me
like I'm a child
you're yeah there's an obvious answer
that's right under 10 under 10 you're
treating me like I'm a child under 10
the answer is 21 year old Cora Miriam
quickly puffs that that is a trick
question that was trig leap up all right
who did anyone happen who had it the
doctor of course the doctor had it okay
next question next one quote sometimes I
like to listen to Taylor Swift in my
room and cry about cats that have died
Fame that's gotta be is definitely from
tumblr over 28 year old god no I'm just
kidding it's it is it which is it that's
an 8 year older it's old it's an eight
year old Bickley I don't trust the rest
I really got it okay one for Emily to
four-bit lay the doctors leading okay
next quote mom dad you need to help me
oh come on yeah we're all saying over 20
it is in fact over 20 that is for your
old sign I don't resist protest pathetic
okay so we all go to that one next one
all right never resist adulthood I
really being human but some days I
really wish I could just be a fairy
that's how always I'm gonna say under 10
I don't think is a woman or a girl named
Emily at 4 years old
hey all right all right so none for
Emily we got really depressing
the next one is quote can I wear a bear
costume at your wedding as I'm the ring
bearer I am a werewolf
I'm alright you go on right back at it I
feel like this is a trick this is 28
year old other candidate named Riviera
so who got that I get that I got it you
know you don't recognize other kin when
you hear it so in other kin for did you
say over 22 yeah okay I have to put that
so please other kin is a one of the 56
genders that now exists according to
Facebook and probably every university
in the country and other kin is it's
like a trans species but not a real
species like a fake species so like I
think I'm like a werewolf I think I'm
gonna hell yeah there was that
well that's there that's a different
thing I think they're also furries it
gets very free
yeah we'll get into that later I'm sorry
keep going Marshall okay next one is I
am made of gold treat me like it I'm
gonna go on your 10 millennia all right
the answer is that is a 20-something
woman's sign at the woman's March rally
in Washington DC is are you tonight I
like that line I tell myself that in the
mirror every morning I would have a
poster of that on the wall
I am gold alright the next one is quote
it's about creating a home here isn't
gimme but it's really sad than it's a
gimme is Geralyn
right that is Geralyn Luger a Yale
undergraduate Michael's old best friend
yeah that's that is that's my old my old
professor Gerald Luthor coming at you
quote Donald Trump is a bad man what do
you say that for he just is Donald Trump
is a bad man what do you say of where he
just gives given that logical
progression I'm gonna say over 20 I'm
gonna this is Kylie six years old but I
lost my lead
yeah Lee got it let's see who's know ok
so right now the doctor doctor Bickley
and Ally are tied Oh
all right let's break that tie with the
next quote I don't vote I don't do no
moaning yes under 10 this is famous
rapper and Coachella headliner Kendrick
Lamar right oh sorry
quadric Donald Trump hates brown people
I'll say over 20 right I could see some
sunlight College person saying that
whoever votes in oh yeah that's your
final answer
okay sure this is Chelsea Handler 42
years old
LSP and ler Ali the only one not
together
we all knew I didn't know his handler
though okay Chelsea all right next one
close one
I know Trump hates brown people that's
the same quote I know Trump people with
brown skin that's still the same is that
is a different quote this is a different
quote this is trying five years old it's
hard to hold on I guess we had the
Bickley was picking up on her system I
would have missed it yeah we're tied all
right
guys next one quote if Donald Trump
becomes president I'm gonna be super
super mad and I'll move to a different
world I don't know actually getting
nervous about this now I yeah it could
have been like any celebrity I guess
overt we all say over 20 okay this is it
Blake five years old it's really sad
that we can't differentiate it this is
really sad none of us guys the last
quote okay all right so by the way so
right now Ali and the doctor are tied
this is the type quote if he would it be
elected I'm moving to Jupiter also also
basically the same quote I'm gonna go
under ten couple this is Sharon age 1410
just share sure you got it oh you both
all right let's get out so Emily and I
lost there's a tie between the good
doctor Bickley and Ally but you know
what none of that matters because there
are no winners and losers here at the
Michael Knowles show there are only
participation trophies thank you all for
participating I feel like we're all
number one don't you feel like we're
just all I'm supposed to be I'm supposed
to be this is not about an intellectual
space it's about creating a home here
that's what that's gonna be the morrow
of my show okay
panel thank you all for coming on we
have got to stupid we've got to get to
the important news of the day that was
the news to me of the day that was the
most important news to me now before we
get to all of this important news about
Republican propaganda and Jimmy Kimmel's
craziness and meat-eating vegetarians
and shrieking women who are being mean
to veterans we have to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube I know you want to
watch more we have Allie Stuckey in
studio best day ever but in order to do
that you have to go to daily wire calm
you have to pay $10 per month $100 per
year has nothing you know what you get
for all that you get me you get the
Andrew Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show I know what
you're thinking so what so what this is
what the left is tears tumblr this it is
the perfect vessel for all of the
leftist tears and they are flowing day
by day I actually have a beautiful Jimmy
Kimmel vintage 2017 in here right now
it is absolutely indestructible it's
made of crushed up steven crowder mugs
that have been consolidated into I think
titanium I think that's how titanium is
made so go over to daily wire comm right
now we'll be right back
[Music]
panel MSNBC is now reporting that quote
Republican propaganda efforts reach new
alarming level they're referring to a
piece that's out in the AP that shows
that the Republican Governors
Association now has a website the
Republican Governors Association is
publishing a website it's called the
free telegraph and it publishes stories
that the Republican Governors
Association wants you to hear this is
obviously alarming because now
Republicans have a very tiny media
outlet dr. Begley as an expert what is
your take on partisan media throughout
American history as a doctor I feel it a
millennial vaguely bad about it mm-hmm
but I feel that this you know the story
I looked at the MSNBC report on it which
is more hyperbolic than the AAP even
which is and the the sense of like
there's no self-awareness with these
media outlets about the absolute
monopoly they have on all the major
outlets the print TV overt bias even all
of their reporting and they're really
outraged about it and there's there's
one thing that I'll give them that I
think is actually legitimate I do think
initially the Governors Association
should have made it very clear they were
actually sponsoring it they didn't for a
second ap called them out they put that
at the bottom of the website II with
that disclosure great whatever bring it
on you know what they're not asking and
they won't ever ask this is why did they
feel than this necessity to actually
create this thing there's a reason right
this there's no Democrats creating this
they don't have to
so they're not going to look at it like
that they're gonna have the sensational
headlines and the other self-awareness
of MSNBC reporting on AP reporting on
this yeah oh there's the echo chamber
there's the echo chamber there was that
study that came out that 93% of
mainstream reporting about Donald Trump
has been negative compared to reporting
in the 40s about Obama and in the 50s
about Bush there is this huge bias in
the media but all of this is even
relatively recent the there were always
partisan media outlets in the United
States there was the Tennessee Democrat
there was the Oklahoma Republican and
then starting after World War two we
started to have the so-called objective
journalist outlets Ali you're a
journalist you do real news and fake
news what what happened was there ever
really an objective media moment in the
United States I do think that it's hard
to deny that we've become in our
journalism increasingly biased
especially when we don't have all of the
facts of the story case in point Russia
it's been reported as fact for probably
over a year now and yet we don't even
now after a year of reporting have
nearly enough facts to be able to say
that he is guilty that Trump is guilty
of fresh collusion and yet it's been
reported as fact I don't think that used
to be the case I do think that in
yesteryear it used to be let us gather
all the facts that we have and then let
us come to that conclusion but rather we
start with the conclusion and then we
back up from there and I think that's
where it gets dangerous I do agree it's
much clearer now we can clearly see
which we know that MSNBC is left-leaning
they say it they say lean forward on
their commercials and we know that the
free Telegraph is sponsored by the RGA
but I'm even reminded of Walter Cronkite
the so-called most trusted man in
America he unilaterally conceded the
Vietnam War he said the word was lost
when the war was not lost so maybe it's
clearer now but I think it
I think was always there and just maybe
more insidious Emily do you think that
we need an objective media or should we
just have the right in the left and the
Republican and the Democrat press shops
fighting with one another and we piece
them together and get all the facts how
do you even go about getting an unbiased
media source there is no unbiased media
so how would you even make one yeah
we're all people we all have our own
biases we're all I'm gonna write it or
at least our own point of view
at least our own point of view and I
think that the burden is much less on
media outlets first of all I think it
was very funny that they called the free
Telegraph like masquerading as news
because I mean let's look on Vice yes
any documentary that pretends to be
informative even though it was like
little Vox bubble videos they do or
they're educating you and they're
informing you it's explanatory
journalism what kind of other journalism
is there by the way journalism is
supposed to be explanatory to know that
climate change from Vox has educated me
that climate change is actually the
cause of the Syrian conflict hmm but
they've read your attitude yeah so you
know woke Emily I read in via woke you
are it's it's tough it's not easy being
this well but I think that first of all
the lines are blurred as to what is news
and what is media you know it's all
information it's all biased there's no
way we can come up with an unpardonable
we can only make our biases clear and
secondly the burden is the burden is on
the reader the burden is on the absorber
of information to go back and understand
what that is I was listening to an NPR
clip a long time ago that live on NPR
the reporter said that Trayvon Martin
was shot by a white man Oh white
Hispanic man yeah you know that white
Hispanic man there's no there's no way
to like report that there's no way to
like say you know George Zimmerman was
not I couldn't call in you know it's up
to us to know what
the research is to do it on our own and
to avoid fake news sites like the
Washington Post in The New York Times
The Daily wire perhaps and the day
that's you're in the telling wire that
they did the left analyst us is like the
number three biggest fake news site out
there I don't know that we've ever run a
fake story by the way but Natalie
to the left all right we need to get I
mean the news is hilarious right now but
you know what isn't malarious is
late-night comedians Jimmy Kimmel is
getting back in the humorless partisan
hack business with his latest rant about
Republican health care reform not only
did Bill Cassidy fail the Jimmy Kimmel
test he failed the Bill Cassidy test he
failed his own test and you don't see
that happen very much this bill he came
up with is actually worse than the one
that thank God Republicans like Susan
Collins and Lisa Murkowski and John
McCain torpedoed over the summer and I
hope they have the courage and good
sense to do that again with this one
because these other guys who claim they
want Americans to have better health
care even though eight years ago they
don't want anyone to have health care at
all they're trying to sneak this scam of
a billy cooked up in without an analysis
from the bipartisan congressional budget
office they don't even want you to see
it ha ha ha ha ha ha ha good one Jimmy
alley do you remember when Jimmy Kimmel
was funny me neither
[Laughter]
he's wrong he's factually wrong I'm
sorry but do you remember when
Republicans eight years ago didn't want
people to have health care is there
anyone that you know in Congress who
doesn't want people to have health care
yeah chorus we want them dying in the
streets I thought right yeah yeah that's
what the memo said at least from The
Daily Telegraph by masquerading as a
comedian and it's sad that we see people
won and complete health care and health
coverage and then and then just use
their platform that's supposed to be one
of comedy and entertainment as a way to
as a way to present fake news and
alternative facts and then they turn
around and tell us that we're the ones
who lie and that we're the ones who
didn't pass our own test doesn't make
any sense
Emily this guy is not like Bob Hope or
Johnny Carson Johnny Carson was actually
a pretty left-wing guy he very rarely
talked about his politics and interviews
occasionally he would let it slip a
little bit I favored more abortion or
higher taxes or whatever virtually never
on air he just was a great late-night
host who told jokes whither self control
among late-night comedians why is it
going away first of all the Daily Show I
think I think when we go back to where
does news and and media begin where does
entertainment start and information end
it's all sort of rolling into one and
then especially since we've gone through
this extremely partisan political
election you're looking at people who
want to make politics funny and it's
funny haha because everybody's gonna
laugh along with me because if you don't
you're you're the person in the wrong
problem yeah it's like what Liz Lemon
said on 30 rocks but she's like ain't no
party like the Liz Lemon party because
the Liz Lemon party is mandatory but I
do want to ask the question is that the
the one thing that I was noticing that
Jimmy Kimmel didn't say there's two
words charlie guard try that didn't even
occur to me that is that is the defeater
for era for this exact argument there
that's how government healthcare works
is a cryin determined family trying to
save their son will be told absolutely
no by the government wanting to bring
him to the country with the best best
health care in the world
but I thought we have the worst out here
I thought Jimmy Kimmel told me we have
mm-hmm that like Cuba yeah yeah like
Cuba with all of their empty hospitals
absolutely right that that is a really
great point because there's this a
little bit of compassion that we feel
and we don't realize that the road to
hell is paved with good intentions and
that a government that can give you
everything you want can also take away
everything you have and that and that
isn't funny I ain't laughing Jimmy
doctor Bickley
you know the whole the this to me wraps
into the argument about the discussion
about the bias thing and I think there's
been a you know like a more and more
thorough embrace of relativism where you
think well there's there's no truth
you know from the left and thus you know
you
present your own facts right and I feel
like the same thing is happening from in
the entertainment business where it's
like there isn't this is our our whole
ideology or something like that hangs on
even the entertainment industry now and
it's sort of a we're all gearing up
toward presenting our truth and our
reality and that's sort of overtaking
the purpose of the the different medium
and nici episode this is he's lost that
he's lost a sense of like what what am I
actually here to do I'm here to
entertain I'm here to in a wide audience
as wide as possible that's not that's
not actually was trying to do he's
actually thinks that he is he's there to
propagate an ideology mhm
it is the tail wagging the dog and he's
excoriating Bill Cassidy senator Cassidy
for promising one aspect of health care
reform and then changing it slightly
whatever happened to if you want to keep
your doctor you can keep your doctor and
then millions of Americans lose their
health insurance and lose their doctors
you know he seems to have forgotten
about that he's shocked he has the tears
in his eyes is it though I wonder that I
mean these guys are all professionals
they're all showbiz guys is it that they
are so moved by their ideology that they
can't help but push it all the time or
do they think it's gonna get them better
ratings in this fractured politicized
media environment the Jon Stewart Point
is a great point because I think they
saw a lot of these similar minded
entertainers so like a real success
story there and think that they can
imitate it even no one's been able to
pull it off no ever Noah can't do it
who's a talented enjoyable guy that's
kind of generally likable he's pretty
much flopping yeah it's not he's
definitely not significant like Jon
Stewart Jon Stewart every week would
make headlines and it would matter it
wouldn't move the needle and it would
move the conversation none of these guys
can pull it off but I think they think
they can do it you know and I I think
there's so much ego I mean even his he
his tests he names it the Jimmy Kimmel -
Julie Q understand that he's he's in a
dialogue with the with the congressman
but he's but he still he embraces it he
is the test mimimi and if you don't if
you don't actually meet his standards
you fail the test and that's what
matters
well that's what the framers talked
about right then good good legislation
for the republic had to meet the jimmy
kimmel test it's in Federalist 59 or
something yeah yeah the section shows
surprise they're able to see that far
ahead in the future to know who Jimmy
was that's right well you know speaking
of the the tribute that vice pays to
virtue in hypocrisy according to a new
study at a Britain one out of three
self-identified vegetarians eat meat
when they are drunk which is a little
strange because I eat carbohydrates when
I'm drunk I eat beets and stuff who
knows different strokes for different
folks Ali yes does this mean that we
cannot trust how one self identifies
perhaps it really made me think this
study you know is that if I was in that
situation I want biscuits
I want bread I want toast all the things
just I just wonder what it is about like
them I just want a juicy steak after a
few beers that it is but I think it does
um yeah it does beg the question are you
are we who we think we are sober in vino
veritas as has always been my mantra
Emily these a third of vegetarians are
eating meat when they're when they're
drunk does it perhaps suggest that
mankind is meant to eat meat that we're
built to eat meat and we should stop
with these Gnostic and ridiculous
heresies that tell us that we have to
save Gaia by only eating lettuce and
things like that um absolutely as a
millennial absolutely as a millennial as
a vegetarian get me a drumstick we're
never supposed to eat me mm-hmm
this is this is absolutely forbidden um
don't eat anything that has a face
that's right you know I I hear this all
the time so vegetarian that leaves us
with only other Millennials to be
that's true they certainly don't have
any channels that's right men without
chests doctor you're an expert what do
we make of this crazy study well again
as a doctor you know I feel like there's
truth that comes out when you're drunk
but there's it's not all truth man does
you know it's not all true have you ever
experienced this you do some bad things
happen when you're drunk yeah I mean
sometimes it's just the thing that I
don't let myself do I do
yeah is that who you are that's a hard
question okay does this mean that people
shouldn't be vegetarians that we should
eat me because they eat meat when
they're drunk do you have to apply that
to every alley man's heart is evil from
the beginning okay maybe we don't want
to indulge our darkest fantasies like
Chicken McNuggets or say maybe it
actually means that we're not supposed
to eat meat because you are making bad
decisions when you're drunk and if
they're eating pepperoni when they're
drunk then maybe that just means we're
just all supposed to be vegetarians
snaps you've convinced me we have to
move on in viral video news this thing I
woke up actually Ali I think you tweeted
this ad this morning that's where I saw
it it will get you your daily dose of
outrage this will make your blood boil
[Music]
Marshall I might cut it off right there
do you by any chance have a translation
of that into English do you have any
distribution of that exchange yeah
that's about what I heard - that video
for those of you who couldn't see is a
woman in a dining establishment
screaming at a military veteran for
carrying in his PTSD service dog Wow
Emily how has America gotten to this
place um that's a really difficult
question I don't think I can answer but
I think it just circles back to
Millennials I agree I blame Millennials
- fair enough for me doctor all sad
succinct are we so ungrateful
why are we so ungrateful that's hard to
watch man that's really hard to watch I
don't I don't have a response to that
video you're all it's it's actually here
it isn't it is a little less coverage
you can't come up with an i it's so
shocking to watch that you don't believe
that it's really happening
you know only 2% of people in the
country today have ever served in the
military the 2% of the country has ever
served in the US military
does that explain our ingratitude during
the the world wars during the greatest
generation everybody served in the
military or is it is the essence does
the ingratitude come from ignorance of
what these people have gone through
Ellie it shouldn't because it's
Millennials I mean we've been in a war
the majority of our lives where are we
we have no we haven't gone over there
that's very true and you do make a good
point but we're familiar with it
probably in a way that people over here
weren't when the great world or when the
great wars were going on simply because
of what we can see in the media and how
many of our own contemporaries have
fought
no you said it's not a lot but we've
been familiar with it our entire lives
so I think the ingratitude has nothing
to do with the percentage of people that
have actually fought but just again this
attitude of entitlement that we have
been indoctrinated into feeling just the
the deference that people feel both for
their country and people who bought for
their country it's just not where it was
and almost it's become a bad thing to
honor the vets and to honor the country
and the flag and the Pledge of
Allegiance and all of that and so I
think it's just a lack of deference and
just an apathy towards anything that has
to do with patriotism and it taking for
granted of the freedoms that we have and
you're right that we have seen images of
this war we've seen it on TV we've seen
it all over the Internet
but you know what I think I don't think
they see the guy protecting their
freedom I think all they see is Abu
Ghraib and they see these random memes
that are usually incorrect on the data
that we've killed all these civilians
and they have no sense why we actually
went there in the first place they have
no sense with regard to Iraq that the
policy of the United States government
since the 90s was regime change in Iraq
that the policy of United Nations was
regime change in Iraq that they have
made they had chemical weapons programs
that they had had a nuclear weapons
program they don't have any of that they
just see America bad and they and they
hate their country they don't respect it
it does seem to be echoes of the Vietnam
War
we is it ever thus is there any way out
of this apathy and this ignorant of
where our own freedoms come from solve
it all for us Emily tell us the answer
yeah have everybody sign up for the
military well make it like Israel make
it mandatory is really hard I don't know
a very strong guy I don't I just kind of
was hoping I could like read a blog or
something don't you think that's what we
need you think we need a national system
I think you need to read more blogs I
think you need to give up me yeah and I
think you need to enlist in the
militants in the military at least one
others it might be helpful to the
country
definitely the blog mm-hmm dr. Bickley
final thoughts yeah you know I think
it's it's more it's even more to me it's
even worse than a lack of respect or
something there's actually been such an
undercurrent in education
of animosity
vilification of the military in general
and then I think also would it
complicates things with Iraq and stuff
it's one thing to fight against the
white Germans but I think racism the
idea of racism has so saturated
everything you know it's like every it
is it impacted the view on everything
racism is the greatest evil right and so
just by Americans fighting people of a
different recognizably different race
it's already got this negative
connotation that's right World War two
was the best war ever as some historians
have called it because it's equal its
other European but this is different
that that's an insightful point that I
hadn't considered how do we have every
woman how do we fight the brown people
that's how we're gonna leave it on dr.
Berkeley's profound question in
America's military future that is our
panel excellent discussion today Ali
thank you for coming in Ali Stuckey from
the blaze Emily Butler and the good
doctor himself dr. Billy
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show get your mailbag questions in
will change your life tomorrow tune in
then and we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]